hey guys it's Tuesday July 26th I'm Mary
and you're watching GameSpot news by far
the biggest story to hit today were
rumors on Nintendo's new console the NX
it's portable it's got detachable
controllers
it's got cartridges it's got it all
according to Eurogamer a number of
sources have confirmed the NX will be a
powerful handheld device but it'll also
have controller modules that can be
attached to both sides of its screen the
system can also be connected to a
docking station to use on a big screen
this base unit effectively connects
what's described by Eurogamer as the
brain of the NX housed within the
portable device to a TV but they go on
to state that the NX will use cartridges
as its physical media of choice Nintendo
has a long history of using cartridges
for portable gaming devices it's unclear
what capacity these cards will be
available in modern games on ps4 and
Xbox one can store up to 50 gigs of data
the NX will reportedly run on a
proprietary operating system designed by
Nintendo not Android which has been
suggested by previous reports more
recently Nintendo confirmed the NX
global release date is in March 2017 but
we don't know anything else
officially most this stuff is in the
form of rumors but the more we hear the
more likely it seems telltale have a
pretty good thing going for them they
find a popular series and make a game
about it and then they make a bunch of
money so there's really no reason to mix
it up but they're gonna do it anyway the
new Batman game they're adding
multiplayer we don't know a lot about
Telltale's upcoming Batman series but we
can't tell you one weird thing it's not
gonna be exclusively a single-player
affair think of it like most of
Telltale's adventure games but now you
can allow others to participate in the
decision-making process the developer is
aware that its players are sometimes
accompanied by people who like to chime
in when a game presents a choice Batman
will be the first of its games to
support this new crowd play feature so
now the world can help you decide when
Joker will remember that finally all the
free games you get with xbox gold in
August have been revealed they are as
follows xbox one games include Warriors
Orochi 3 ultimate and WWE 2k16 the Xbox
360 games which are also playable on
Xbox one are spelunky and
good and evil HD the first games warrior
and spelunky will go live on August 1st
the other two will join them on August
16th Xbox Live Gold members who claim
them either through their console or the
Xbox website will have unlimited access
to the games for as long as they remain
gold subscribers you can still claim the
current slate of games with gold titles
two of which the Banner Saga 2 and Tron
evolution will leave at the end of July
so get those while you can so that's all
the news I have for you today but be
sure to check back again tomorrow we'll
have some more security that hobo is
back we'd arrest him but his eyes are
just so blue